hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focus Channel and my name is Paul today
I want to start this video with a new
feature called the mystery language I'm
going to play a language for you that
you may have not heard before and at the
end of the video I will let you know
what this language is so check it out
SAS accent any custom console denim Lisa
found Rana datacom normal Okinawan back
10 malakas antenna la casa de armas
cajas and mush Arikara can folks in the
faction missional watch away recently
Pitt Slim is not an Julia ok stay tuned
until the end of the video and I will
tell you what language you just heard ok
on to our main topic what country has
the most languages spoken what country
is the most linguistically diverse many
of us come from countries where there
may just be one or two main languages
and maybe some other regional minority
languages too but there are some
countries in the world where the amount
of linguistic variation is just
mind-blowing
the country with the most languages
spoken is Papua New Guinea with at least
eight hundred and twenty different
languages spoken imagine that Papua New
Guinea is a very rural country where 88%
of the people live in rural areas now
compare that to 10% of the people in the
United Kingdom living in rural areas or
19.3 percent of the American population
living in rural areas Papua New Guinea
is very rural indeed and because of
Papua New Guinea's rugged terrain and
it's deep valleys there's a limited
amount of communication between all of
those isolated rural communities that's
why there remains such an amazing amount
of linguistic variety today without any
particular languages sort of growing in
influence and dominating the others
imagine that your village speaks one
language and the neighboring village
just a few kilometers away speaks an
entirely different language that
sometimes the case in Papua New Guinea
and I'm not even talking about different
dialects at the same language although
that happens - I'm talking about
completely different languages in
the languages of Papua New Guinea fall
into three categories the first one is
the Austronesian languages which arrived
in Papua New Guinea about 3,500 years
ago
then there are the Papuan languages
which predate the Austronesian languages
in Papua New Guinea and then there are
the foreign languages and Creole
languages that serve as lingua Franca's
the term Papuan language simply refers
to languages that predate the
Austronesian languages languages that
are indigenous to Papua New Guinea it
does not mean that they are a single
language family there are actually
several dozen different language
families amongst the Papua languages
some of those language families have no
connection to each other and there are
some language isolates that means that
there are individual languages that have
no known connection to any other
languages in the world most pop one
languages are spoken by only a few
hundred to a few thousand people though
there are a few that are spoken by over
a hundred thousand people there are
three official languages in Papua New
Guinea the first one is English
the second is Tok fishing and the third
one is Kitty MOTU the most widely spoken
is talk listen it is an English creole
language which arose during the colonial
period top fishing is now used as a
lingua franca which is very important in
a country with so many different
languages and it is also now spoken as a
native language by many people so pissin
is less widely spoken in the southern
region of Papua
where a different language often
functions as the lingua franca and that
is kitty mo - Kitty MOTU is a simplified
creole of another Austronesian language
called motive its use has been declining
in recent times in favour of English and
top pieces English is only spoken by one
to two percent of the population but it
is widely used in business and it is
supposedly the language of education but
if english is the language of education
and only one to two percent of the
people speak it then that sounds like a
pretty dodgy education system to me the
second most linguistically diverse
country in the world is indonesia which
lies right next to Papua New Guinea in
fact half of the island of New Guinea
lies inside Indonesia about seven
hundred and forty languages are spoken
in Indo
but there is only one official language
and lingua franca and that is bahasa
indonesia or Indonesian number three is
Nigeria with five hundred and sixteen
languages spoken but English is used as
a lingua franca especially in the urban
areas
I guess they need English to communicate
with all those thieving oil companies
number four is India with 427 languages
the main lingua Franca's are Hindi as
well as English which was left behind by
the British colonizers in exchange for a
massively huge amount of India's
resources and number five is the USA
which has 311 languages now that may
sound surprising because we think of the
USA as an english-speaking country but
remember that there are over a hundred
indigenous languages in the USA even
though many of them have a very limited
number of speakers these days there are
also a couple of hundred of different
languages spoken by immigrants to the
USA it may be hard to wrap your head
around that huge degree of linguistic
diversity especially if you are
interested in one of those countries
that you want to learn a language to
communicate with the people there but
luckily those countries all have one or
more lingua Franca's which can help you
communicate with a much larger
proportion of the population from
various different linguistic communities
thank you for watching the Lang focus
Channel be sure to check out my social
media links like Facebook Twitter
Instagram and Google+ and also check out
the lang focus com blog as well the
mystery language from the beginning of
the video was the Malagasy language from
Madagascar for more information on the
Malagasy language click here and visit
the lang focus website thanks again for
watching have a nice day
you